the goal of this video is to try to
figure out the anti-derivative of the
natural log of x and it's not completely
obvious how to approach this at first
even if i were to tell you to use
integration by part you'll say wait
integration by parts you're looking for
the anti-derivative of something that
can be expressed as a product of two
functions it looks like i only have one
function right over here the natural log
of x but it might become a little bit
more obvious if i were to rewrite this
as the integral of the natural log of x
times one dx now you do have the product
of two functions one is a function a
function of x it's not actually
dependent on x it's always going to be
one but you could have f of x is equal
to one and now it might become a little
bit more obvious to use integration by
parts integration by parts tells us that
if we have an integral that can be
viewed as the product of one function
and the derivative of another function
and this is really just the reverse
product rule and we've shown that
multiple times already this is going to
be equal to the product of both
functions
f of x times g of x times g of x
minus
minus the antiderivative of instead of
having f and g prime you're going to
have f prime and g
so f prime of x
f prime of x
times g of x
g of x
dx
and we've seen this multiple times so
when you figure out what what should be
f and what should be g for f you want to
figure out something that's easy to take
the derivative of and it simplifies
things possibly if you're taking the
derivative of it and for g prime of x
you want to find something where it's
easy to take the antiderivative of it so
a good candidate for f of x is natural
log of x if you were take the derivative
of it it's 1 over x let me write this
down so let's say that f of x is equal
to the natural log of x
of x
then f prime of x is equal to one over x
and let's set g prime of x is equal to
one
so g prime of x is equal to one that
means that g of x could be equal to
could be equal to x and so let's go back
right over here so this is going to be
equal to
this is going to be equal to f of x
times g of x well f of x times g of x is
x natural log of x
so g of x is x
and f of x is the natural log of x i
just like writing the x in front of the
natural log of x to avoid ambiguity so
this is x natural log of x
minus the antiderivative of f prime of x
which is one over x
times g of x which is x
which is x
dx
well what's this going to be equal to
well what we have inside the integrand
this is just 1 over x times x which is
just equal to
1. so this simplifies quite nicely this
is going to end up equaling this is
going to end up equaling let me i can go
let me put it right there this is going
to end up equaling
i'll write x
natural log of x
minus the anti-derivative of just dx or
the anti-derivative of one dx or the
integral of one dx i should say the
anti-derivative of one is just minus x
and this is just an anti-derivative of
this if we want to write the entire
class of anti-derivatives we just have
to add we just have to add a plus c here
and we are done
we figured out the antiderivative of the
natural log of x and encourage you to
take the derivative of this for this
part you're going to use the product
rule and verify that you do indeed get
natural log of x when you take the
derivative of this